It's not easy dating
when you're naturally reserved
and don't go out of your way
to meet new people on a daily basis.
But there are many benefits
to dating an introvert.
As you get older,
you may get sick and tired
of meeting new people,
who only want to have a good time.
Instead, you began to
find yourself wanting more.
Here are 5 reasons why
introverts make the best
relationship partners.
1. They can teach you
to take less for granted.
Introverts are observant
and notice the little things
that are commonly overlooked.
This means that they have
a keen eye for unique moments.
They also know how to slow down
and learn to appreciate things
in the present.
As why as in individuals,
they don't see life as a race.
They know how to pace themselves.
So, if you catch yourself constantly
feeling burned out or stressed,
because you're always
looking for the next big thing,
unline with your partner,
and learn how to enjoy
what you have now.
2. They make you their top priority.
Are you unsure about entering
a long-distance relationship?
If your partner is an introvert,
you won't have to worry about
be cutting less important to them.
In fact, introverts tend to excel
in long-distance relationships,
because they put a lot of effort
in making things work for their partner.
Considered and reliable individuals,
they are great in making
an practical schedule
that lines up with yours.
Introverts also tend to enjoy
going out of their way
to bring joy to their partners.
Because that's how they demonstrate
their love and dedication.
For long-distance relationship tips,
please be sure to check out
our video here.
3. You can count on them
to be there for you
on your bad days.
Maybe you just got laid off,
or maybe you're dealing
with some family trauma.
Whatever the case may be,
if you need to have a good cry,
know that you can do so
on your partner's shoulder.
Introverts make great listeners
and excellent problem solvers,
because they know how
to absorb information
and pick up on useful details.
Of course, no one's perfect
and it's impossible
to have all the answers,
but introverts are careful and earnest
in times of emergencies.
How matter how big
or loud the storm is,
They know how to provide the com,
which is incredibly refreshing.
4. You always feel like
there's something interesting
to learn about them.
Introverts are naturally mysterious by nature.
They prefer not to put
all their cards down at once,
and slowly warm up to others.
So, if you're dating an introvert,
be thankful that they chose to let you in.
Since introverts tend to
internalize their thoughts often,
their inner worlds
tend to be complicated,
yet rich and full of imagination.
They make deep thinkers
and always seem to have
something interesting to say
when you least expected.
5. They're in it for the long haul.
Looking for a one-night stand?
Then look for someone else,
because you've got the wrong person.
Introverts like to weigh all their options
before making any decisions.
This makes them (?),
responsible and level-headed.
If an introverts chooses you
as their partner,
then it means they see a future with you.
We all know that
excitement eventually wears off
after the first stage of relationships.
But this never discourages introverts.
In fact, they don't care
about the adrenaline rush,
So you'll know that
your partner's serious about you,
because they have
a good time with you regardless.
Good luck out there!
Introverts are an illusive target.
It might just be best to set up
the Netflix fate and wait.
But before you go,
subscribe to Psych2Go,
And remember to let us know
any of your experiences with introverts.
Also, don't forget to check out our Patreon
for some Psych2Go perks.
Thanks for watching!